all right i was not initially going to
do this story so many of you wrote to me
about it that i i'm going to do it but i
want to again mention that there's a lot
going on right now with ron desantis his
wife is is in cancer treatment and i
just want to be careful with with this
story
um the back story on this is that ron
desantis the republican florida governor
who maybe mismanaged covid more than any
other governor in the country at least
up there in the top five
basically went missing publicly for two
weeks uh on december 17th a bagel place
in ocala florida posted a picture of
desantis being there desantis was then
missing from the public for 13 days on
december 30th posted a picture from that
same bagel place the same picture saying
go get bagels but at that point we knew
that picture was almost two weeks old so
it didn't really allay concerns about
where is he and the speculation was did
he have coveted and he had to go out of
the public eye for some period of time
because he didn't want to publicly admit
that he had coveted it was speculative
without a doubt
then it was stated no no no
ron desantis was busy
going to his wife's cancer treatment
completely legitimate except the
statement was that that was only on
december 29th it doesn't really explain
his 12 days of absence dating back to
december 17th on new year's eve desantis
surfaced at a big concert with his wife
who again is immunocompromised she's
undergoing cancer treatment no masks
very very dangerous thing to do and the
speculation continued to be was desantis
hiding covid for that period of time
a video has now been released from
yesterday
in which
ron desantis something is very wrong
with ron desantis his voice is quivering
he's out of breath he's struggling to
breathe kind of like trump when trump
remember when trump left the hospital
with covet and he defiantly took off his
mask
and then you could see
trump really really struggling to
breathe it's a similar thing with
desantis but at the same time
he kind of seems almost in tears and
maybe there was a setback with his
wife's treatment so let's take a look at
it and we i don't know what's going on
this could be
the additional evidence that he's been
hiding kovid could be that his wife had
a bad treatment day or a setback i don't
know but let's take a look and let's
take a listen by dane eagle who's our
florida
deo secretary
we also have chancellor henry mack from
the florida department of education
so this part is more coveted like which
is when you speak speaking is more
effort than people might realize
and a lot of times with kovid
it's this having to really
labor each breath to keep speaking so
far later it seems more like he's almost
crying
brad ferguson senior vp and general
manager skywater florida and dale miller
site director skywater florida um as
well as representative fred hawkins
manufacturing
is something that we need and you can
hear that breath is you know you you the
the the multiple short breaths to try to
keep up with the oxygen he needs better
job of and we've worked really hard in
florida to have
more opportunities with vocational
education we have expanded our
manufacturing footprint in the state of
florida and we want to continue to be
able to do that
as we go forward
so now is where it starts shifting into
it's not just the trouble breathing he
starts to sound on the verge of tears
semiconductors are a huge issue
if you look at how the supply chain
works
we are overly dependent
on foreign nations
including taiwan which is a good ally of
ours but which is one that
excuse me which is one that is
under really serious pressure from the
communist party of china and so we have
an opportunity to do more here in the
united states and i think the more we
can do manufacturing of semiconductors
here the better off we'll be
so today i'm proud to be awarding six
million dollars to build infrastructure
that will connect southern osceola
county to the emerging neo city
technology district this district is
already home to six companies including
skywater technology a u.s owned and
operated semiconductor foundry while
this award will support nearly 5 400
jobs osceola county officials estimate
that this could lead to tens of
thousands of jobs once it's fully
developed as osceola county continues to
grow
i'm also awarding valencia college with
3.7 million dollars to create new
programs that focus on workforce
training for chip and semiconductor
industries through this program students
will be able to be certified in
operating repairing and designing the
robots that are used to create
semiconductors in just 14 weeks
valencia estimates that in the first two
years 120 people will be able to
graduate and immediately find work at
the neo city technology district all
right so listen i mean i want to be
careful with this
his wife has cancer it would be logical
to be crying if her treatment weren't
going well but we don't know what this
is certainly you know the back story
he's missing two weeks posts a picture
that's two weeks old to show that he's
actually out there says he was
accompanying his wife to cancer
treatment but that apparently was only
on one day 12 days in
and then reappears using accessory
muscles to breathe and taking these
short gasping breaths and and just
having a it's it's all weird it's all
really weird and it reminds me of trump
on the white house balcony after taking
off the mask
and breathing like that and we know why
we we know uh you know what the reason
was for trump doing that so are are we
ever going to get the truth i don't know
is it reasonable to think that desantis
would hide kovid if that's what he had
yes
absolutely
i mean there's no doubt in my mind and
this was
there was the idea of hiding trump's
covet as well and it became impossible
it was just it's not going to be
possible once the facts became known uh
of how serious it was once the reality
sort of set in
but absolutely desantis would hide covet
is that what this is i don't really know
one of our sponsors is cometier coffee
the world's first frozen coffee i've
been very impressed with the coffee i've
had from cometier cometier sources their
beans from some of the world's best
locally owned specialty roasters and the
cometeer team has developed their own
way of protecting the freshness and
aroma of the coffee by taking its
concentrated liquid form and flash
freezing it so it keeps those original
flavors and nuances comets here comes to
you frozen you just add hot water or for
iced coffee you just melt it you can use
it to make a ton of different hot and
cold coffee drinks the way they lock in
the flavor like this you really can
taste it it tastes fresh
i've been getting a ton of enjoyment out
of cometier they've got a great variety
of coffees it's delicious the way you
make it is super convenient and you'll
get twenty dollars off when you go to
cometier.com pacman the link is
underneath this video